hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to on
September 4th 1975 Gene Siskel and Roger
Ebert got together and they performed a
revue show where they looked at movies
it would eventually be called Siskel and
Ebert on February 20th 1999 Gene Siskel
passed away and on April 4th 2013
Roger Ebert passed away I bring this up
in this order for very specific reason
when many duo's inevitably break apart
usually they can't survive on their own
because so many people see them as the
duo they've seen them is that for
several years but what was so cool about
Roger is that he was never just and
Ebert he was never and Ebert he was
always Roger Ebert he was never the
other guy and the reason for that is is
because they both had such potent strong
personalities that they could survive
just as well on their own as they could
together
imagine way back when when they were
first starting how many people were just
scratching their heads and how angry
they could get at each other over a
movie most people said that's not gonna
change anything it's just a movie it's
mindless entertainment what made both of
them so incredibly interesting to watch
though is that not only did they get so
personal about it but they saw film as
important and they would always stress
how important the film is they would say
not only is it art but they would say
this is a representation of what's going
on right now this is showing us what's
being valued what's not being valued
asking questions like why is something
that many critics say is good not being
a success or something made critics
don't like is a success what's I say
about us what's that say about other
people what's that say about what's
popular right now what's that say about
culture but what always showing through
with them whether they hate is something
or they love something was they had this
incredible
passion and that's what people I think
really related to even if you totally
disagree with them on something they
just had this passion for what they did
I don't know if how many people really
keep in mind how many movies these both
these guys would review they would
review five movies a week where most
critics do - sometimes you know maybe
three they would do five every week and
they would write about it and also do
the television show about it I love
you're probably saying oh really like
that's really hard and stuff like that
to make it constantly entertaining and
constantly make people want to come back
and hear your opinion on something yes
that is difficult for five movies a week
that is difficult so many people I think
going into any kind of criticism or
appreciation of art or film or
literature or whatever they think it's
mathematics or a science and it's not
Gene Siskel graduate bird showed that
this is about what you bring to it or
what it can bring out of you or what it
delivers or any of that stuff it's an
it's a journey it's an experience is
what does it do for you and what are
different points of view of looking at
it there is no right or wrong way of
looking at something and they're the
only people who can actually say there's
a right and wrong way of looking at
something they will look directly to
each other and say you are wrong but
they could get away with it they could
get away with it because you knew they
were getting caught up in how
passionately they loved cinema and how
much they knew it represented they would
get so vulgar and so angry and what we
found out watching them why we kept
watching them because we thought that
the reason we like these guys so much
and we enjoyed hearing them argue about
this stuff was because they were taking
something that clearly isn't important
and to talking about like little
children but what we were really
enjoying was how passionate they were
because we said to ourselves without
even knowing it if we had just an iota
of that pair
for anything in our lives whether it be
bill or books or games or people or
anything we be preset like we would have
a lot of good things going for us
because no matter what happens we would
have that undying passion that roger
ebert have from movies and Gene Siskel
had from movies the kind where they
would yell each other they would get
personal they would get so angry but at
the same time they could get so happy
about what they review they could be so
thankful for the job that they have
because they would see something like Ed
Wood or Fargo or any of these other
incredible films frigging Beauty and the
Beast the Disney animated film they will
go on and on what a perfect wonderful
movie this is and that's for kids it was
a children's animated film and they took
it just as seriously as the adult films
because they took film that seriously
there was nothing that they said oh this
is just for children just were older
people just for teenagers just for
whatever they took it all seriously
because they knew it represented what
was going on they knew that this was
important it's the equivalent of taking
like that famous illusion of DC and ugly
old lady or do you see a beautiful young
woman it's the same thing it's not like
Ebert would come in and be like no it's
a young woman that that's it there's
nothing else there no he would say look
at it from this point of view I know you
may see something ugly but take a look
at it from this different point of view
the way I see it and at the very least
give yourself an option to see it from
this point of view that was what was so
cool about Roger Ebert and that he loved
discussing that he loves sharing but
even after Gene Siskel died he still
kept it going with other reviewers you
know Eber Roper and other critics that
he had on and he would just keep it
going cuz he loved the discussion it was
obvious he loved the discussion a lot of
you probably know that I did a tribute
to Cisco and Ibrahim
and I am so pathetic that I still have
that goddamn tweet framed I might be the
only person to ever frame a tweet and
the reason I bring that up is because
once again this shows just how humble a
guy he could be and the reason is that
I'm not a filmmaker I'm not in Hollywood
I'm not doing any of that stuff I'm not
even really in the great scheme of
things that huge a name but he saw this
video from a guy he never heard of you
know I never watched and he saw this
tribute knowing that I wasn't from
Hollywood I wasn't a big-name director
wasn't any of this stuff and he not only
said it was a good tribute he said it
was the best he had ever seen
and for someone who clearly must be made
aware that he is the most famous movie
critic in the world to go out to this
this kid who just made something you
know in his parents other room with this
little camera and one or two lights this
guy was put so much passion and
everything to say that was the grace
he's ever seen it's meant the world to
me it's meant the frickin world to me
and there's times where I said to myself
god I gotta look up where he's up
hearing next when he's gonna do his next
books on your weather cuz I just want to
say how much that meant to me
I was literally saying that the other
day like two days ago I was saying that
and now I will never get that chance but
here's what I do realize is that given
how intelligent this guy is and how
aware of his status he was and what a
big name he was he must have known how
much of an impact he had not just on me
but on so many of us he must have known
how much we appreciated him because I
don't think he would have shared as much
if we didn't listen as much if we didn't
accept him as much it really was a
two-way street because we would keep
saying tell us your opinion your opinion
is actually a voice for us
if we disagree with you we can see that
you are a voice that I understand that
even if you say this is crap the way you
talk about I might say well hey I might
like this or vice versa if you love
something and maybe I can hear the way
he talks about I don't think I would
like this because we did feel like we
knew him so well because he shared so
much with us and he shared his passion
with us he was the guy that made
everyone want to be a movie critic and
not for the reasons you would think
everyone wants to be a movie critic not
because they get to complain and get
paid for it
not because it looked glamorous not
because their opinion carries so much
power but because he had that passion he
had that love for it and we were just
wishing we could get just the tiniest
bit of that passion and love and I think
by sharing that with us we did we did
get so much of that passion and love and
he was kind enough to share it with us
and to be honest about it
he never at anything everything
was straight forward and you knew that
just by seeing him talk about it and he
would confess when he was wrong he would
fight when he thought it was right this
really was a rare person who changed
more than even I think he's aware of and
it really really breaks my heart that
he's gone but what I do know is that
what he has left us is a great education
about movies about understanding movies
about the passion of loving movies and
that's a greater education that I know I
couldn't teach I know so many other
critics couldn't teach but he found
their way and he did it so unbelievably
well and I can say very honestly so men
people got it we heard it and we loved
it and we loved you roger ebert I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and you will always be
remembered
you